you are the executive producer of the
new gong show yeah the gong show classic
show being brought back you're the
executive producer you got some great
talent on this show some great celebrity
judges we got some amazing I called in a
lot of favors
and we got some great people some really
funny people we got we got your gal
fanatic off in a kiss we got Jack Black
we got Jennifer in Branson yeah we got
Elizabeth Banks Will Forte Fred Armisen
we got a bunch of people that were
amazing incredible yeah incredible yeah
that was awesome to get all these great
talent yeah I waited by the phone a
while yeah we uh we thought about you
they they they actually asked do you
want to ask Conan and and I said um I
said not my cup of tea
this doesn't doesn't make me doesn't
make me laugh you know and but but I
love them hang on but I love them a lot
no that's not true that one bought that
at all no actually I did ask you you
were busy you did ask me yeah I just was
like what I'm not doing that so now we
didn't come up what they down where's
your boom yeah
you were let go the one you'll go to
charity and as a charity I want that
cash you can't make a crowd
[Applause]
my gravis finally come true they're
really good at it too your dream is a
crowd booing me and my dream is that I'm
shaking like yours you won't catch your
parking ticket in your mind I can see
you in your mind you've always been like
an angry old man did the gun show we had
amazing we had amazing guests we had
amazing talent or if you call that come
on the show and do their acts people
gonna see it I think they're really
gonna love it it's a great show that you
can watch actually with the whole family
and you can be weirded out you can be
disgusted right it sounds fun yeah
you